[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs comme chaque jeudi
des idées sorties pour profiter de son
week-end dans les yvelines et tout de
suite le sommaire de cette semaine un
mix de boxe et de fitness la savate
forme est une discipline qui est ludique
et technique tv 78 à tester une séance à
maurepas découvrir l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
autrement grand sportif ou débutants de
nouveaux parcours d'orientation vous
attendent et l'agenda complet de vos
sorties au programme des ateliers du
théâtre et du cinéma et au début de ce
set 8 loisirs avec la découverte d'une
discipline n'est développé en france à
votre forme ali ludique et technique 7 %
des licenciés de la fédération française
de savate la pratique tv 78 a choisi de
la tester regarder de la boxe sans
affrontement un peu de fitness et un mix
qui donne la savate forme et c'est le
score qu'a décidé de tester tv 78 et
pour l'occasion nous sommes accueillis
par l'école de boxe française et savate
des lampions et de maurepas
[Applaudissements]
alexandre bonjour bonjour vous allez
être mon coach aujourd'hui mais déjà
qu'est ce que la savate forme alors la
savate forme c'est une discipline de la
fédération de boxe française de savate
boxe française et donc l'idée c'est de
mettre les techniques de savate boxe
française en musique et en mode fitness
avec la possibilité aussi lorsqu'on
souhaite d'ajouter aussi et d'autres
disciplines au sable peut faire un
cercle de ça va être défendons tous les
coups de coude ratés techniques
donc l'idée c'est de fait ce n'est de
faire les cardiologues fatigué en
musique est ensemble et en chorégraphies
et dans un autre esprit pratique et les
mouvements de la mer ça s'adresse
inquiet en tunisie sur s'articuler à
melwood oui oui c'est la pluie très
restreint c'est tout ce qu'ils veulent
voilà donc en général on a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de filles puisque
c'est les filles notamment le public
féminin qui est attiré par tout ce qui
est fitness et et musique
[Musique]
c'est convivial par contre c'est
cérébrale quand même faut bien réfléchir
et tout et puis voilà on se dépense ou
s'amusent et puis c'est une bonne
ambiance
j'ai fait d'autres sports à côté que
j'ai abandonné finalement je reste à
votre femme parce que c'est familial je
trouve ça cool c'est vraiment un sport
complet qui nous correspond moi j'aime
bien parce que ça travaille beaucoup de
cardio et ça permet aussi de quand on
n'ose pas faire de la boxe quoi c'est
une introduction un coq qui débute comme
toute activité par un échauffement
les exercices peuvent véritablement
commencé endurant s'essouffle selon
denise et le mot clé c'est de compter
on en est à une heure de cours comment
je suis déjà bien essoufflé après un
petit show qu on démarre femme très très
vite j'ai peur de la suite
finalement la suite reste dans le rythme
un peu de cha-cha-cha comme l'appelle
alexandre un travail à deux en face à
face
un bon moyen de travailler la
coordination et les réflexes
[Musique]
si vous aussi vous voulez pratiquer la
savate en deux rondes et dc proposé par
le club
moi je vais les métiers h
[Musique]
si vous voulez plutôt assisté un match
il ya ce rendez-vous de handball féminin
montigny le bretonneux reçoit dreux ce
samedi soir à 20h30 au gymnase pierre de
coubertin
une rencontre très importante pour les
inhumant tel dans ce championnat de
nationale 2 après 15 journées elle
occupe la troisième place du championnat
à un point de la 2e place la montée est
donc encore possible
on parle maintenant à lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines sandra
buron bonjour bonjour vous êtes membre
de l'équipe communication événementielle
de l'île de loisirs aujourd'hui on se
rencontre parce que les de loisirs lance
de nouveau circuit d'orientation
pourquoi des nouveaux alors des nouveaux
parce que les anciens étaient en place
depuis une quinzaine d'années et depuis
une quinzaine d'années il ya eu beaucoup
d'aménagements qui ont été faits sur
l'île de loisirs en terme de travaux de
changement de configuration du site
évolution de la végétation aussi donc il
ya des bornes qui devenait difficilement
accessibles ou
des bornes qui était détériorée aussi un
puisque si on est avec des bornes en
bois donc forcément ça une durée de vie
limitée
et puis les gens qui pratiquaient
régulièrement finissait par aussi
connaître par coeur tous les parcours
donc il y avait besoin d'un renouveau
voilà que ce soit en termes de typologie
du site ou pas pour recréer un petit peu
de nouveautés pour les gens qui
pratiquent
il y en a onze de nouveau oui il ya tant
de choses à découvrir finalement dans
l'île des loisirs
on peut la voir de 11 manière différente
oui alors les onze c'est surtout parce
qu'ils ont des longueurs différentes
on va avoir un parcours d'initiation qui
va être d'un kilomètre et demi avec des
bornes plutôt en bord de chemin assez
facile à trouver jusqu'à des parcours
qu'ils vont faire tout le tour de
l'étang donc un peu plus de 8 km ou là
va y avoir 22 bornes à trouver et puis
des bornes beaucoup plus difficile à
trouver où ça demande un petit peu plus
d'expérience sur la lecture d'une carte
pour voir les différents reliefs et les
différents éléments remarquables sur une
carte pour pouvoir le trouver et en plus
parmi ces 11 parcours il ya des points
de départ différents donc on va avoir
quatre parcours qui vont partir là de
l'accueil mais on va aussi avoir des
parcours qui vont partir du centre
d'hébergement pour quand on a des
groupes qui viennent en séjour va y
avoir un parcours au niveau du centre de
voile et un par d'autres parcours qui
vont partir de la salle des bernaches ou
de l'espace événementiel quand on a des
team building entreprises ou des
événements comme ça un petit peu plus
ponctuelles donc il ya différents points
de départ différentes longueurs et
différents niveaux de difficulté donc
voilà c'est doux léonce parcours
justement ça s'adresse à qui ce qu est
ce qu on peut le faire en famille quand
on n'a jamais fait le petit parcours
justement de alors nous les parcours
sont sont réalisés alors par des
familles qui vont venir qui peuvent
faire le plus petit le moyen le long peu
importe
après ça on a beaucoup de scolaires
aussi qui viennent sur sur ces parcours
et puis on s'en sert avec avec les
groupes qui viennent au niveau du centre
d'hébergement ou d
des demandes entreprises sur des team
building ou des choses comme ça où on
l'aimé un peu plus sous forme de
challenge et qui peuvent être
chronométrés ou des choses comme ça on
va rajouter après des éléments
difficulté mais on va dire que les deux
principaux se sont famille et scolaire
qui profite des parcours d'orientation
d'un point de vue pratique il faut
amener soi-même sa boussole ou lille
fourni tôt au moment de la prise de la
carte
alors lille fourni tout au moment de la
prise de la carte
on ne fournit plus la boussole parce
qu'on à part sur des personnes
expérimentées mais qui en général on
s'assure leur montre où les fans peuvent
le téléphone portable on se servir de la
boussole
les cartes sont suffisamment précise et
détaillée pour ne pas avoir besoin d'une
boussole pour pouvoir s'orienter parce
que malgré tout il ya beaucoup de
cheminement on n'est pas au milieu d'une
forêt ou d'une plaine ou d'une step plus
complètement isolé fabrice que de
retrouver quelqu'un le lendemain non à
la norme allemande jamais retrouvé
personne qui n'ait pas retrouvé la
sortie ou le bout de jeunes donc
effectivement la boussole était un petit
peu plus secondaires alors parfois s'est
demandé sur les scolaires parce que les
maîtresses veulent apprendre donc là on
les fournit mais sinon non non vous
venez les mains dans les poches avec une
paire de baskets et voilà on vous donne
la carte et puis après vous pouvez
partir sur le parcours pour les infos
pratiques justement il faut réserver on
peut se présenter à l'accueil n'ont rien
a besoin de réservation pour les groupes
pour les scolaires voilà là on va
demander une réservation parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de cartes qui vont partir d'un
coup et puis pour éviter qu'il y ait
trop de monde sur les parcours en même
temps pour les particuliers non dans ces
homos au niveau des horaires d'ouverture
de l'accueil pour pouvoir fournir les
cartes
et puis après on l'est on les récupère
mais voilà pas besoin de réservation
vous venez comme vous voulez plus à
faire par tous les temps tant qu'on est
bien pour le parti c'est tout à fait oui
c'est possible par tous les temps merci
sandra burel rien si vous voulez vous
testez rendez vous à l'accueil de l'île
de loisirs
[Musique]
les amoureux du jeu sont attendus à
saint cyr à l'école la commune propose
son deuxième saint cyr ludique
une journée où le jeu est à l'honneur
jeux d'ambiance de réflexion d'aventuré
de stratégie l'animation débute à 10h à
l'hôtel de ville a voté le prisme vous
propose une pratique tout à fait inédite
celle de la percussion corporelle
à l'occasion de la venue des filles ce
monde qui dans la salle et dans
courtoise 3 mars prochain un atelier
proposé le dimanche 1er mars un moment
pour transformer son corps en
instruments et c'est plutôt une envie
d'aller au théâtre l'espace coluche de
plaisir accueil simon abkarian le
comédien propose une tragi comédie dans
laquelle il célèbre ses racines
méditerranéennes
il rend aussi hommage au théâtre de la
grèce antique une pièce où les femmes
jouent un rôle de premier plan on
regarde un court extrait
[Musique]
c'est toulalan que tu aurais dû te parle
et c'est le moment de parler de cinéma
cette semaine c'est lui que beaucoup qui
vous invite à venir dans les salles
obscures
on part donc au ciné cette d'elancourt
[Musique]
alors plusieurs coups de coeur cette
semaine un peu comme d'habitude aussi 17
mai bon l'actualité fait que c'est ainsi
donc cette semaine c'est le début du
festival contre champ où les femmes sont
à l'honneur puisque la thématique du
festival cette année ces femmes rebelles
donc si vous le souhaitez vous pourrez
venir découvrir vendredi à 20h45 en
avant première le très beau film
mignonne qui sera précédée d'une petite
conférence sur les femmes dans le cinéma
et d'un petit pot d'amitié comprendra
tous ensemble autre avant première cette
semaine au ciné cette le très réussi de
gaulle avec lambert wilson sur la vie je
chemine en du général de gaulle que tout
le monde connaît et enfin le coup de
coeur du ciné cep cinéma cette semaine
c'est un film qui a déjà sorti à trois
semaines très beau film de léo karman
qui s'appelle la dernière vie de simon
dont venez voir ce film on va le garder
au ciné c'est parce qu'on le soutient
parce qu'on aime les eaux et on aime son
fils c'est un très beau fils de jean un
très beau premier film je précise
fantastique très réussi d'aucuns disent
que les os et le nouveau spielberg c'est
tout ce qu'on lui souhaite
mais c'est un film avec des acteurs paco
d'une peu connus tour le propre frère de
léo martin karman qui s'en tirent
remarquablement bien et il est vraiment
à découvrir une très très belle histoire
je vous en dis pas plus mais vous on a
une 6,6 et en cette semaine au 6 et 7
nous venez nous vous attendons avec
plaisir
[Musique]
la fête de la musique c'est le 21 juin
prochain mais la ville de plaisir
recherche déjà ses talents si vous
souhaitez vous produire lors de la
soirée organisée à la caserne des
pompiers envoyés dès aujourd'hui votre
bon de démo vous pouvez candidate et
jusqu'au 15 mai c'est la fin de ce set 8
loisirs merci de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez revoir cette émission en replay
sur notre site internet tout notre
application mobile on se retrouve jeudi
prochain à tv soissons sur tv 78 à 18h30
pour de nouvelles idées sorties
[Musique]
m